part two of the advice that changed my  self-image so for those of you that  didn't see part one i was complaining to  my friend that i just felt stupid and  you know she tells me that all the  things that i'm complaining about  feeling stupid in  are things that i'm not interested in  and when you're bored of course you're  gonna feel like the dumbest person in  the room i realized that the people that  are really truly intelligent and truly  great at what they're doing are the  people that are just so interested in it  don't get me wrong your iq definitely  plays a role and i'm not overlooking  that some people are just born smarter  but i realize that i'm never going to be  the smartest version of myself  unless i'm following the things that i'm  passionate about and the things that i'm  interested in